[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de
l'algérie de la france et de l'algérie
un passé qui ne passe pas la france et
l'algérie entretiennent des relations
aussi passionnelle que conflictuelle
leur actualité est toujours rattrapé par
un refoulé avec des exigences de
repentance d' excuses
d'épuration mémorielle de disputes sur
les archives et de ressentiment
coloniale seulement la guerre est finie
la france n'a plus de colonies au
maghreb les accords d'evian et
l'indépendance de l'algérie date de 1962
le présent franco algérien est aussi
économique avec des guerres réciproque
notamment avec la livraison
d'hydrocarbures et de céréales en cette
période chahutée par le conflit en
ukraine la crise migratoire elle est
impacté par la question des visas et les
deux pays sont astreints à coopérer dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme au sahel
si le dpi ont intérêt à une coopération
en veillant à leur souveraineté
réciproque ils n'ont pas encore trouvé
ce fil d'ariane politique qui sied à
l'entente harmonieuse entre nations nous
allons chercher à dépoussiérer le passé
et envisager le présent de cette
relation franco algérienne avec mes
invités l'écrivain boualem sansal qui
est avec nous en visioconférence il est
écrivain son oeuvre est universellement
connue vous est traduit dans de nombreux
pays et je vous remercie d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui pierre lellouche
politologue ancien ministre est depuis
toujours intéressé aux questions de
politique étrangère pierre vermeren vous
êtes universitaire vous connaissez bien
les questions du maghreb et yamina
benguigui vous avez été ministre et vous
êtes réalisatrice vous venez de publier
enfin il ya quelques temps un film soeur
[Musique]
pensez vous qu'il soit utile aujourd'hui
de rechercher un consensus mémorielle
sur la guerre d'algérie alors que les
deux pays diffèrent dans leur
appréciation
historique des événements boualem sansal
qu'est ce que vous en pensez écoutez la
situation est absolument inextricable
il ya eu deux périodes de temps les
relations mémorielle et historique
contre l'algérie la france
de l'indépendance jusque on va dire
jusqu'à la fin du mandat de monsieur
chat glee dans 88
la relation était sûr sur charles à la
question historique elle est plutôt
bonne
mieux ce n'était pas un sujet
d'actualité
peut-être les spécialistes en parallèle
mais pense a passé assez inaperçu
pourquoi parce que le pouvoir algérien
avait
son instrument de légitimation c'était
la guerre il était victoire il a mené
une de la falaise a mené une guerre
contre la france il était victoire était
dans une position au salut leur stade
c'était à la france de se juger de juger
son passé colonial et de faire les
gestes qu'il faut du vaincu au vainqueur
ou encore et puis voilà c'est que après
88 le peuple algérien est sorti dans la
rue à rejeter tout ce processus de
légitimation
du pouvoir par l'histoire
la légitimité historique et là le
pouvoir s'est trouvée peu mieux comment
se légitimer en restant en place comment
légitimer alors
l'a20 d'historique avait été rejeté par
la population les gens étaient sortis
dans la rue dir il y en a marre de
toujours ou parlent que d'eux que de la
guerre que de du passé que des héros que
des libérateurs on veut vivre on veut
veut voyager on veut sortir s'amuser
étudier on veut profiter rives comme
tout le monde c'était ça le discours des
années
donc d'abord le train a été détaillé par
les islamistes les islamistes nous on
veut riendeau à dos ils ont rendrait le
peuple et l'armée le pouvoir dorado mais
ici voilà la légitime une autre
légitimité s'est mise en place la
religion et les islamistes ne sont pas
intéressés par l'histoire c'est
l'histoire l'islam les relations entre
les musulmans et les chrétiens et donc
problématique se pose différemment
donc nous on s'en fout quand un français
fait la guerre à l'algérie que
n'ont jamais parlé de ces questions là
et
la légitimité religieuse ne sais quoi
c'est de
convertir le c'est d'essayer d'imposer
si vous la légitimité religieuse ans
l'algérien ça a été assez facile puisque
les algériens sont musulmans il donc
ça a été relativement facile pour les
islamistes de nous amener de vous
ramener au bercail de de ramener du
mouton à la bergerie et ben c'est comme
ça que le peuple s'est finalement rangée
ou osi vers l'islamisme à la guerre
civile cette légitimation ne fonctionne
pas ok le pour le pouvoir g13 prêtait
pas donc comment se positionner par
rapport au monde et barrabourg la france
et par rapport au peuple
et d'un point de vue politique
aujourd'hui alors
de poids du bes écoutait pouvoir
algérien fait ce que c'est et poutine
ont
en ukraine face au moose et créer un
état de crise
la crise permanente pour détourner
l'attention pour noyer le poisson c est
ça semble fonctionner les français sont
tombés dans le piège à pieds joints ils
répondent aux questions il se lamente
imac leur compte y reconnaîtront merci
papa génocide mais peut-être deux ou
trois génocides et marc pierre lellouche
on a planté le décor avec boualem sansal
sur ce consensus mémorielle c'est une
bonne ou une mauvaise idée pour dr
chercher à obtenir un consensus bêtise
sans nom
c'est un non sens
l'algérie est indépendante elle a son
histoire sa mémoire mais ça rien à voir
avec nous nous les français on a un
problème qui est que la relation avec
l'algérie n'est pas une affaire de
politique étrangère ça devrait beaucoup
de sujets avec l'algérie mais c'est une
affaire beaucoup de politique intérieure
parce que il ya les pieds noirs parce
que il ya des harkis et parce que on a
eu des vagues migratoires considérable
algérien depuis première deuxième
troisième génération
vous avez des millions de gens qui ont
une histoire et que l'algérie en france
et en face une une classe politique
littéralement tétanisée par la
complexité
de ces communautés de leur vécu et de
leurs relations avec la république donc
le problème il est franco français dans
sa dimension migratoires et sa dimension
d'intégration sa dimension mémorielle
par rapport à ceux qui ont subi la
transplantation elle a été difficile moi
je les subis tunisie je m'en souviens
encore j'avais cinq ans quand il 70
aujourd'hui ces trucs qui marquent à vie
tout le monde est marqué à vie
maintenant avec l'algérie ce qu'est ce
que vous voulez croiser les mémoires ça
n'a aucun sens j'entends le président la
république nous expliquer qu'il faut
croiser les mémoires et benjamin stora
ce livre est de grandir ce qu'est ce que
ça veut y aller les algériens ont fait
d'une guerre d'indépendance qu'il
considère avoir gagné bien il ya des
accords de paix pour les sur le d il ya
eu le départ des colonisateurs des
colons ont souvent été des gens
extrêmement modeste d'ailleurs enfin
toujours est il que cette histoire elle
est terminée de souhaiter la menons vont
vous tourner vers le passé
en 1960 62 algérie c'était à peine 10
millions de personne tout compris
compris les européens aujourd'hui c'est
pas de 45 millions de personnes la
majorité des algériens n'étaient même
pas nés au moment de l'indépendance ils
sont d'un pays extrêmement jeunes
extrêmement riche le problème de
l'algérie c'est sa gouvernance et il
faut pas que la mémoire servent de fonds
de commerce à une mal gouvernance
permanente qui condamne ce pays où se
développe en est à l'émigration ne sait
jamais ce ver chez nous et là nous avons
le problème mais c'est pas vrai
mémorielle c'est un problème politique
et je pense qu'il faut sortir de deux de
ce petit jeu de mémoire l'algérie de
s'intéresser à cette gouvernance et à
son avenir et tourner la page de le
faire pour la jeunesse algérienne
ne rien dire de recommencer la guerre et
les français doivent regarder l'algérie
comme un état tiers
indépendant mais bien sur guerbert
vermeren 2 il ya une confusion entre
mémoire et histoire et qu'il faudrait
laisser à chacun des pays
établir sa vérité historique et ne pas
chercher à trouver une mémoire commune
moi j'ai été élevé par un père qui a
fait la guerre à l'allemagne et il
m'interdisait d'aller en allemagne et
j'ai assez vite compris qu'il y avait ce
serait difficile de réconcilier
la mémoire de l'allemagne et de la
france alors non oui l'histoire c est là
justement une vocation pacificatrice
parce que chacun raconte son histoire
son histoire nationale son histoire
familiale
cette question de la mémoire elle et
elle est intéressante mais si vous
voulez c'est une affaire de personne
c'est une affaire de personne de
communautés de groupes qui ont vécu la
guerre d'algérie aujourd'hui ces gens là
sont quand même
de moins en moins nombreux ils souffrent
ils ont souffert il se rappelle des de
leur jeunesse puisque avec la vieillesse
vient le temps de revenir de réécrire de
relire sa vie donc ça c'est très bien
mais pourquoi on parle de la mémoire
avec l'algérie et on parle d'histoire
avec tous les autres pays du monde alors
c'est vrai qu'il faut reconnaître que la
situation est quand même très original
pour deux raisons elle a été très
original à l'époque coloniale parce que
la france avait un projet fou en algérie
elle a eu le projet comme l'avait fait
sur la rive droite du rhin ou dans les
pays bas au moment de la révolution
française de transformer cette terre
qu'elle ne connaissait pas en une partie
de la france bonzi de balorre c'est une
utopie c'est sané en plus sinon les
mêmes valeurs
ils n'y ont pas mis les moyens ils l'ont
pas fait sérieusement et en fait
aujourd'hui on paye les ors de la
troisième république mais enfin c'est
comme ça un siècle et demi après donc ça
c'était exceptionnel un projet fou ce
qui fait qu aucun pays au monde n'a vécu
ce qu'ont vécu les algériens ça on peut
l'entendre méo et al'inverse en deuxième
temps on a une histoire post coloniale
exceptionnelle avec l'algérie du fait de
cette migration exceptionnel aussi vous
savez les marocains il ya un tiers des
marocains qui sont à peu près immigrés
qui sont en france mais dans le cas et
aehi les diasporas dans le monde y en a
partout elles sont généralement répartis
dans le cas de l'algérie entre 8,9
algérien sur dix qui n'existe pas en
algérie algérien et descendant de
l'algérien sont en france donc ça crée
effectivement des conditions tout à fait
exceptionnelle et donc une exception
plus une exception plus des groupes qui
souffre ça donne la situation actuelle
il aux politiques qui sont très
sympathiques et qui n'ont pas fait
d'histoires qui n'ont plus vécu ces
événements et qui regarde ça avec
effectivement la main tremblante sans
comprendre vraiment salamina benguigui
vous avez l'avantagent
à côté d'eux d'un point de vue politique
de faire du cinéma est d'abord vous avez
fait récemment un film qui s'appelle
soeur quand vous avez fait ce film vous
avez cherché à concilier les mémoires où
vous êtes parti finalement d'un point de
vue historique qui était le vôtre iq et
qui n'avait pas qu'ils n'étaient pas là
vouloir concilier deux histoires
apparemment ne sont pas les mêmes vues
d'un côté ou de l'autre
alors avant de parler de soeur je vais
vous parler d'un autre film j'ai
commencé par un film qui s'appelle
mémoires d'immigrés
et avant de parler de ce film je vais
vous je suis franco algérienne je suis
né de deux parents algériens
et vous avez la nationalité française
mais c'est grâce au cinéma que je me
retrouvais mon identité mes origines
lire les racines aussi de mes parents
moi je trouve qu'on peut pas parler de
la france et de l'algérie de l'algérie
de la france de sa composante ici comme
ça simplement comme parler d'un autre
pays comme parler des sénégalais des
maliens n'ont et jamais nous n'aurons
jamais cette histoire ensemble elle est
partie d'une histoire violente c'est
l'histoire de la colonisation et ses
soubresauts après quand j'écris mémoires
d'immigrés c'est que nous sommes nés en
france nous sommes de parents algériens
nos parents ne nous ont pas raconté le
pourquoi de notre naissance ici et de
notre présence l ailier totalement à
l'histoire de france dans les accords
d'evian il y à un accord de main
d'oeuvre la france demande à l'algérie
de garder toute sa main-d'oeuvre
algérienne sinon c'est l'hécatombe dans
les usines françaises
c'est à dire il ya des grandes
discussions entre le patronat français
l'état et l'état algérien c'est à dire
que il y à peu près
1 million 800 mille voire 2 millions
personnes en france et en
1974 subir ce qu'il faut continuer à
faire tourner les usines du nord de
france les usines de voitures ce n'est
pas un choix par exemple que les mères
viennent en france on va organiser le
regroupement familial
mais aujourd'hui nos jours nous sommes
le résultat de cette histoire donc
aujourd'hui nous avons nous quand on
parle des mémoires nous avons notre
génération à écrire notre histoire pour
nos enfants pour ne pas qu'ils se
trompent d'histoire un jour quand
moody's note générale en islam is ouvert
des choses ou ouvert par exemple lorient
alors que notre histoire elle est liée à
à à cette méditerranée donc mon travail
de cinéaste csssae depuis des années
mais il ne faut pas oublier cette
histoire qui a était
caduc chaotique est pour nous très
violente parce que on a organisé des
choses pour nos parents quand on parlait
tout à l'heure de la migration on se dit
tiens ils sont partis un matin ils
viennent ici en france nous nos parents
m'ont été gérée vient après
l'indépendance le regroupement familial
et après lorsqu'on fait l'aide au retour
mais ce sont pas les bras on peut pas
faire toute l'histoire de l'immigration
non je veux vous dire aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui important pour moi de vous
remettre ça un peu bien compris
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui dans
ce que moi j'ai à raconter parce que je
ne pourrais pas faire d
voilà vous dire voilà l'algérie c'est
comme ça la france c'est comme ça je
peux pas y être c'est à travers mon
histoire chacun se raconte et voient ce
aussi même si on fait mon travail on
travaillait plus sociologique
cinématographique parfois oui mais vous
dites que vous reconnaissez que la
mémoire est singulière on peut pas avoir
une mémoire commune d'un événement
d'abord jamais voilà toutes les
histoires donc
nous savons aujourd'hui ce serait
vraiment de se mettre la tête dans le
sac que la génération des enfants qui
sont nés ici des pieds noirs la
génération des enfants de harkis l'âge
notre génération nous nous sommes le
père qui a mené aussi des combats en
france tout ça nous nous sommes en train
de s'y d'essayer d'écrire nos mémoires
donc elle n'est pas que sur la 1ere 2e
génération elles elles continuent elles
continuent mais vous reconnaissez que un
pays doit avoir des relations avec
d'autres pays et que des exceptions ça
peut pas définir une politique étrangère
pierre lellouche laurent du sujet c'est
très intéressant d'écouter yamina
benguigui d'abord considéré le
regroupement familial comme une sorte de
punition et de transplantation alors
alors ce qu'on a fait tout de suite le
lait de retour non non non je connais et
je connais un petit peu cette histoire
le regroupement familial est un tournant
absolument majeur dans la politique
migratoire de la france on est passé en
76 d'une immigration de travail et une
immigration de peuplement qui fait que
nous avons développée ensuite une
population immigrée et des descendants
d'immigrés avec des problèmes
considérables d'intégration et
d'insertion qu'on n'a toujours pas
résolu et on fabrique d'accord et on
fabrique ce genre de drame de la mémoire
de gens qui savent pas où ils habitent
en fait et qui vous dit attendez moi
j'ai besoin du ma mémoire pour mes
enfants parce que je sais pas où je suis
en fait par rapport à mes racines mon
identité comme elle l'a dit algérienne
dans le beat ici nordique j'ai bien dit
odile permet d'en face avec ça je suis
franco algérien merci on a 11 ans
admettons admettons qu'ils aient cette
complexité jeu-là jeu là je la respecte
la mémoire et je la respecte je reviens
à la question de fond est ce que avec
tout ça la france la république
française d'état français peut quand
même avoir une relation
normale avec un pays étranger qui
s'appelle algérie ou bien est-ce qu'on
va continuer à vivre quantique en or des
décennies mais au delà mettez moi peur
d'être découvert et côté du service de
darcis books et google ebooks s il te
plait permettez moi de demander
permettez moi de demander l'avis de
boualem sansal vous êtes là boualem je
voudrais vous poser cette question vous
avez écrit un livre avec boris cyrulnik
et vous dites que à ressasser
indéfiniment la demande de repentance
jamais c'est une manière d'entretenir
les blessures est-ce que vous qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette chose là pfff
est-ce que ce raisonnement de repentance
permanente n'est pas une manière de
maintenir la blessure
c'est ce que je dis ou début de mon
intervention le pouvoir algérien
instrumentalise ce que nous appelons
d'histoire la mémoire et de revue les
relations du de tous les jours au jour
le jour le pouvoir algérien est
illégitime
il a besoin de se légitimer ou sur la
coopération algéro caresse dans le sens
du poil en invente il est des choses qui
au fond n'existe pas les jeunes
algériens comme tout ce qu'ils veulent
c'est ça les voyages est si vive comme
tous les jeunes du monde entier mais
entre les deux ou trois france et
l'algérie il ya des les apprentis
sorciers qui manipule le tout l'espace
mon idée c'est que c'est à la france de
gérer son histoire et sa mémoire à six
nouvelles chaînes gérer plus en histoire
à la mémoire qui se débrouillent ce que
je dorme sein d'un corps nous sommes
d'accord là-dessus permettez-moi
d'avancé si vous voulez dans ce débat
parmi les sujets qui fâchent autant les
historiens que les peuples il y a le
fait que l'algérie était ou n'était pas
une nation ou une république avant la
présence française alors qui a raison
dans ce domaine de gaulle pour qui une
république algérienne n'a jamais existé
avant 1830
vous prenez mouloud-mammeri qui parle
lui d'une culture berbère de
saint-augustin donc très antérieure où
les responsables actuels âge rien qui
évoque un droit national d'aînesse
pluriséculaire pierre vermeren sur cette
question de nation qu'est ce que l'on
peut dire aujourd'hui si vous voulez que
le peuple qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le
peuple algérien est vécue sur sa terre
depuis l'antiquité
avec des visiteurs parfois très intrusif
personne ne remet la chose en question
mais le nationalisme et la nation c'est
une idée neuve c'est l'amérique qui l'a
inventé c'est les états unis d'amérique
qui ont inventé la nation avec la
révolution et ils sont sortis de
l'angleterre et ils ont créé la nation
américaine déploré boussou nous
les français quelques années plus tard
ont proclamé la nation souveraine à la
place du roi et à partir de là le a
commencé l'histoire du nationalisme il
n'y avait aucune nation en afrique
comme bas reviennent d'ailleurs dame est
nulle part il y avait des empires
ballard l empire ottoman et l'algérie
était la principale province de l'empiré
ottoman donc c'était une province
guerrière c'était une province riche le
dédale j'ai été numéro trois de l'empiré
ottoman c'était une figure majeure mais
ça n'était pas pour autant une nation
donc aller chercher des nations à
l'époque des empires ses vins donc c'est
un faux débat on plaque des réalités ou
celle nationalisme en afrique et dans le
monde arabe c'est une idée du 20e siècle
pourquoi voulez vous qu'ils nation le
seul qui a commencé à penser la nation
algérienne en parce qu'ils étaient les
traits historiens d'état où il avait
étudié en tout cas il avait lu c'est
abdelkader il a essayé au moment où les
français sont arrivés le nombre qu'ils
ont été chassés il a dit moi je vais
créer un étage créé el-watan etc bon
évidemment il est plus rentable il n'a
pas pu aller loin mais il a essayé de
fabriquer vers le losc là dessus
l'empereur napoléon iii rêvait d'un
royaume harb et c'est une des choses qui
souhaitait faire avec abdelkader
justement donc que pierre buren a
totalement raison l'idée de la nation
unies et le moderne
qui est fille de la révolution
américaine et de la révolution française
qu'on a exporté dans toute l'europe et
malheureusement on l'a ans on a pensé à
cette également non plus voilà ça c'est
napoléon qu'il a créé
heureusement même et la colonisation qui
à mon avis est une faute dans notre
histoire épouvantable que nous
continuons à payer tous les jours
la révolution est là la colonisation a
été faite au nom des principes de la
révolution c'est ça qui est terrible à
coude et qu'on voulait exporter s'ils
sont les avoir le point de vue boualem
sansal sur la notion de nation qui
entretient si vous voulez la polémique
on pourrait dire qu'il ya eu un début de
quelque chose il y a deux mille ans avec
les uns les rois numides à la massinissa
jugurtha
avait commencé à
rassembler tout le tour d'afrique du
nord
sous la tutelle de rome d'ailleurs et
ont constitué un empire ait un début de
quelque chose un peuple
comme on l'appelait le nord africain
numide à a commencé et puis bon c'est
tout ça a volé en éclat lorsque
alex est définitivement l'afrique du
nord depuis que nous sommes entrés dans
un point quand csu d'émiettement après
les colonisations musulmane les ottomans
les des vandales les byzantins
etc et puis le délitement cet automne au
19e siècle y avez vous parlé tout à
l'heure de l'émir de kader delhi mme
guérin les maires de kader c'était après
1830 au delà du début de la commission
avant il était un jeune homme qui vivait
au fils de d'imams je crois dans
l'histoire le héros est peut-être que
les hits une idée de a commencé à naître
effectivement ils essaient de créer
alors je sais pas s'il a voulu créer un
nation sur les valeurs
universel ou sur l'islam parce qu'il
faut définir mais ces gens se sont
battus pourquoi est ce qu'ils se battent
pour un territoire ou pour une religion
mais sans moi que c'était au nom de la
religion nous n'avons pas combattu la
france nous avons combattu les chrétiens
qui arrivent et une sur un terminal
lagesse de l'émir a duré dix ans il n'y
a pas de suite il n'y a pas eu et je
vais presser de silence et d'un siècle
il est parti si nous la religion
justement oui mais alors mouallem à
boualem sansal est ce que vous diriez
est ce que vous diriez que la nation
algérienne est la conséquence de la
colonisation française
[Musique]
en fait c'est pas vraiment la france ce
qui a
permis la coagulation d'un certain
nombre de choses c'est la première
guerre mondiale et la deuxième sur la
guerre
d algérie yal des petits paysans des
jeunes se sont retrouvés propulsés en
europe mais voilà ils ont découvert un
monde qui ne connaissait pas du tout
halak est en deux fois ils ont découvert
que
l'europe y sont découverts
autre chose que
ce que le monde musulman leur a bien que
le monde musulman est relativement fermé
se replier sur lui même merci là je vais
dire ils sont revenus dans l'algérie ont
ramené 10 idées de chaudes de libertés
des catégories nouvelles les temps
c'était nouveau le droit le droit
international le le suffit il cela et là
ça a commencé à maturer notamment dans
les milieux du syndic est sécrétée dans
les syndicats français il est parti
français le parti communiste notamment
et c'est chaud ça a commencé à un ami
ajouté à une journée jusqu'au
déclenchement fin du cours
manifestations et répression de 1945 qui
va la cité alors les 300 âmes on va
passer on va passer à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui yamina benguigui
dans votre film soeur
vous rappeler un peu ces événements est
ce que ces idées la décolonisation reste
encore un poids pour les générations les
jeunes générations algérienne est est ce
que vous sentez que la question de la
nation les préoccupent est-ce que cdd
actuels alors encore une fois comme je
le disais au début moi je me situe dans
les suites de cette histoire oui mais on
les a entendu là c'est clair mais là
aujourd'hui
non mes soeurs sa part d'aujourd'hui oui
c'est
[Musique]
lorsque l'histoire sera quand la grande
histoire se retrouve dans la toute
petite histoire d'histoires intimes
c'est à dire ces hommes de la première
génération qui sont venus faire la
guerre d'indépendance en france nous
savons que le mnr et le fln et ils
étaient conséquents et que la guerre
d'algérie c'est aussi gagner ici en
france donc moi je raconte l'histoire
d'un de ces hommes qui est devenu père
et qui ensuite n'a pas supporté au mal
vécu
leur de vivre avec sa famille c'est ce
que je crois qu'à un moment donné ces
soldats n'ont pas été débranchés et ont
ils n'ont pas reçu d'ordre de ce qu'ils
devaient faire pas faire rentrer est ce
que les familles devenait des français d
c'est cette histoire intime là mais
surtout c'est la vision des femmes moi
je raconte toute cette histoire par le
prisme des femmes deux des mères qui ont
aussi mené des des guerres d'un qui ont
participé à cette guerre d'indépendance
et ensuite elles vont devoir se battre
aussi pour l'indépendance de leur fille
mais est ce que c'est ça c'est est ce
que vous constatez que le traumatisme
pardonnez-moi de la colonisation est
encore présent chez des algériens oui il
est présent partout pour une simple
raison c'est que la première génération
n'a pas encore disparu c'est encore une
histoire où les sera content on a aussi
tout est encore neuf l'autre jour je
suis arrivé j'étais en tournage je
rencontre une une dame d'oran pieds
noirs qui s'est écroulé et elle m'a
raconté une histoire il y avait une de
ses filles qui étaient là elles
connaissaient pas l'histoire de sa mère
ont il ya encore ce trop-plein enfin si
peut-être pas aussi grave que ça c'est
peut-être simplement le début de deux de
toutes ces histoires qui vont se
rajouter est-ce que lorsque
les gens qui ont été dans des camps
alors lorsqu'ils vont raconter ça à des
jeunes dans les écoles est ce que c'est
pour attiser de la et non pas du tout
c'est que ça existait et que ça fait du
bien d'en parler et d'échanger moi
maintenant je suis certainement plus
fier de mon histoire donc j'ai pas dire
le mot origines mais de mon histoire de
détrôner dans toute cette histoire parce
qu'aujourd'hui je peux la raconter et
participer à ce récit donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui lorsque je vois la la la
nation algérienne je vois que c'est une
société qui se fait et se défait qu'il
se montre qui se construit que les
jeunes sont très présents au revoir on
va parler de cette chose là
[Musique]
alors parlons de l'algérie d'aujourd'hui
le 22 février 2019 suite au cinquième
mandat avorté d'abdelaziz bouteflika
l'algérie a connu un printemps arabe une
série de manifestations monstres le rire
ac trois ans après à quoi aura servi ce
printemps algéro algérien pierre merel
c'est la question
écoutez ça a permis de voir d'abord que
le peuple algérien il existe il est très
vivant il est très jeune il a plein
d'idées et que c'est pas le peuple a
battu qu'on n'ouvre décrivait il ya
quelques temps
c'est vrai que parce que skins legrand
si vous voulez le dans l'histoire franco
algérienne comme dans l'histoire de
l'algérie le grand mensonge le grand
non-dit le grand
tabou c'est la guerre civile la guerre
civile des années 90 qui a fait près de
200000 morts alors les chiffres sont
contestés certains disent plus de 10 -
peu importe c'est c'est le traumatisme
profond du pouvoir algérien et c'est
pour justement parler à son peuple et à
sa jeunesse je pense que dans cette
affaire il ne s'intéresse pas aux
algériens de france où franco algérien
il parle à son peuple pour reprendre les
choses en main comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure boualem sansal il a fallu on est
revenu à la guerre des contres les
français alors qu'on a choisi un thème
mobilisateur pour occulter donc on a
enfermé le peuple algérien ils ont vécu
10 ans totalement ou 12 ans totalement
enfermé dans leurs frontières il ya eu
la guerre civile la sortie du de cette
guerre a été dur et le premier mandat de
bouteflika est très compliqué les gens
étaient traumatisés pour le coup est ce
qu'on a vu avec le irak c'est justement
que 20 ans après la jeunesse est
toujours là jeunesse à lattes surtout à
l'époque d'internet de la télévision des
réseaux sociaux ils ont envie de vivre
comme il a été dit et il on veut essayer
de dire aux algériens bon maintenant on
tourne la page et on essaye de
construire la démocratie qu'on nous
promet depuis 1962 c'est ça le irak
malheureusement tout d'un coup le
qu'ovide arrive et à nouveau depuis 2
depuis plus de deux ans maintenant
puisqu'on est en mars c'est ça on est à
oui on est à plus de deux ans maintenant
le pays est quasiment fermé à nouveau
pour des raisons totalement différentes
et on a vu bien sûr une nouvelle
génération ouvre deux nouvelles demi
génération arrivée au pouvoir mais le
pouvoir ne sait pas comment sortir
finalement de du très très lourd
héritage de bouteflika de cette grande
espérance qui s'étaient levés en algérie
en 2019 2020
alors bien sûr tout le monde n'était pas
trop fort parce qu'il ya des intérêts à
préserver dans l'état etc mais voilà
donc on sait qu'il ya une autre algérie
de réserve qui existent oui alors
boualem sansal comment vous avez vécu
vous même leur irak et quel bilan vous
tirer aujourd'hui de ce cette explosion
juvénile de liberté dans tout cas de
volonté de rompre avec l'opacité
d'un régime
écoutez je vais certainement m'attirait
beaucoup de beaucoup d'ennuis
mais je dois dire que je n'y ai jamais
cru à ce irak
il ya eu
c'est vrai quelque chose de spontané
le camp nou flicards grabataire ou
mourants quasiment que les adjoints ne
voyait plus depuis plusieurs années
allons ce qu'est le candidat à un
cinquième mandature info qu' évidemment
des gens sont sortis dans
la rue
et puis la mayonnaise semble avoir pris
mais on a très vite découvert que l'or
est dite et
le pouvoir s'était posé la question
suivante bouteflika va disparaître puis
la suite donc c'est une guerre de
succession le irak est en fait la partie
apparente
phase une d'une guerre de succession
petit cas c'était fini il fallait
ensuite se débarrasser de cette partie
de l'armée qui l'avaient soutenu
[Musique]
et puis ces clientèles les oligarques
etc mais ce n'était pas suffisant il
fallait aussi construire quelque chose
pour que la recomposition se fasse
autour de nouvelles forces donc voilà
j'ai quoi ce qui est juste ou quoi le
pays est en faillite
le chômage devrait pas d'argent on
ressort le vieux films de la guerre et
boualem sansal vous voulez dire vous
voulez dire que le pouvoir à manipuler
la jeunesse pour faire une transition
politique qui n'en était pas une
oui des clans du sérail
du scad qui avait été évidemment après
la guerre la guerre civile ont pas
disparu
toujours dans la grande et si ni travail
ils se sont peut-être il s'intéresse
moins à l'algérie sont plus dans une
dimension internationale
l'irak l'afghanistan la syrie
mais voilà donc des stratèges ont su
mettre en mouvement
ou là la chose et puis bon mais des
aigles est jeune c'est bien sûr
romantique et ils ont n'ont pas le sens
politique
ils n'ont pas de connaissances
politiques puisque tout à l'heure où
l'avait dit mais ils vivent enfermés
vous avez dit depuis
la guerre civile à la pandémie il vivre
enfermé l'été 1962 yamina benguigui
votre avis votre avis sur leur irak
yamina benguigui sur le rire assez juste
un vécu quand je j'ai fini mon film
soeur ne devait pas se terminer avec la
fin que je vais vous raconter on peut
pas dire qu'elle vienne les rechercher
et on a tourné pendant vue sur le rnd a
tourné pendant le irak donc physiquement
j'étais voilà je les tournées je me suis
installé c'était voilà je suivais alger
et c'était voilà c'était aussi pour dire
à quel point on nous on perdait nos
réflexions et que là où vous voyez on
voyait un peuple
qui est qui manifester mais qui était
plutôt joyeux qui était plutôt il y
avait
il y avait quelque chose comme ça enfin
en tout cas moi ce que j'avançais dans
politiquement ben on me répondait par
cette vie cette joie de vivre l'art
enfin je voyais les garçons les filles
ensemble il s'est passé quelque chose ça
je l' ai vécu mai 68 alors messieurs
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas connu mais un
peu la même chose il y avait quelque
chose en tout cas qui étaient de l'ordre
des filles et des garçons
c'est ce qui m'a frappé pendant ce
moment là alors c'est pas rien parce que
c'est un pour moi c'était le
croyable de me retrouver là à ce moment
là et j'ai senti ça après effectivement
je ne ne peux pas vous en dire plus dans
le vrai pas vrai en tout cas ce que moi
j'ai vu qu'ils avaient senti ce
mouvement
quelque chose qui était à fin d'une
jeunesse un incroyable jeunesse est un
mélange aussi de deux des familles qui
se retrouvaient là alors que quelques
mois auparavant
les rues étaient assez vide après le
après 18 heures des choses comme ça donc
ça a été un moment incroyable
pierre lellouche voudrais profiter de
votre expertise politique pour situer le
irak
dans la succession des printemps arabes
est-ce que ça s'inscrit là dedans ou pas
je pense que pierre vermeren a très bien
résumé les choses en partie oui bien sûr
le mouvement de ras-le-bol contre les
régimes autocratiques souvent
kleptocrates qui ont massacré le monde
arabe en fait après les indépendances
qui l'ont condamné au sous-développement
à la régression et à l'islamisme en
éliminant toute vie démocratique toute
alternative démocratique donc est-ce
qu'ils restaient les islamistes et pour
éviter les islamistes ont cassé la tête
des jeunes et ont cassé la tête des
opposants c'est qui c'est passé et
malheureusement ce cette révolte de la
base
spontanée donc elle la tunisie au début
est contaminé tout le pays a été réprimé
dans la plus grande violence partout
où il a pu se développer certains pays
qui ont fait ce qu'ils sont restés
fermés je pense aux pays du golfe
notamment mais un le mouvement et est du
même ordre il ya au delà de ceux de
cette poussée populaire qui a été
réprimée par tous
est quelque chose qui est frappant en
mars 2022 dans de la guerre en ukraine
c'est de voir à quel point les régimes
autocratiques
se ressemblent à combien combien le
régime algérien finalement été parce
qu'un copier coller de ce qui se passe
dans la rue dans la russie post
communiste via une gym très autoritaire
des oligarques qui tiennent l'économie
qui sont complètement mari au système de
sécurité armés services secrets
répression totale de la société civile
et une économie à base de ventes de
matières premières et de et
d'hydrocarbures c'est très très
semblable avec en permanence
l'invocation de l'histoire quand il ya
un problème quand poutine à un preuve
avec l'ukraine où quiconque d'ailleurs
c'est les nazis et si la met la faute à
l'amérique et la faute aux nazis avec
l'algérie c'est plutôt binaire c'est
toujours notre faute à nous français
fait qui nous met d'ailleurs dans une
relation complètement schizophrénique à
chaque fois qu'on doit travailler avec
les ailes derrière puisque de toute
façon on est accusé on est accusé tout
et c'est insupportable que leur business
alors c'est un vrai business et c'est
leur fond de commerce en tant que état
kleptocratique et dictatorial assis sur
une société civile qui a envie d'y
normalement cas pas nécessairement envie
de traverser la mer ils ont juste envie
de vivre mais ils peuvent pas donc quand
on va là-bas et j'ai dieu sait que j'ai
été en visite officielle ou accompagnant
des présidents la république est ce
qu'on entend des visas des visages me
souviens de la clameur de la clameur
qu'on entendait à des kilomètres qui
venait de l'université de constantine
quand on ya été avec nicolas sarkozy la
clameur elle monte elle monte elle monte
à mesure qu'on approche et un harnais
des visas des visas c'est terrible comme
un aveu d'échec pour un pays qui a fait
une guerre d'indépendance de voir que la
seule chose qui compte pour sa jeunesse
c'est de partir héhéhé et franchement ça
me ça me révulse un moment très triste
pour ce pays qui a tellement d'atouts
après nous on hérite de cette jeunesse
dont il s'occupe pas et ça c'est un
skull c'est un véritable scandale et
qu'en plus nous on soit on soit complexé
par rapport à ça ça me vous n'êtes pas
d'accord et remis la balle guigui nom et
franchement je suis même gêné d'entendre
tout ce que je viens d'entendre ah bon
tu très très très gêné très fine et donc
je suis même gêné d'être sur ce plateau
vous pourriez très bien faire cette
émission entre vous je suis très gêné et
cette jeunesse qui vient en plus après
chez nous c'est pas possible
ah bon non mais faut arrêter de parler
comme ça faut arrêter de parler comme ça
parce que ce n'est pas
un
mendiant il ya des problèmes de société
certes mais est ce qu'on peut parler de
l'algérie avec moi en la regardant un
peu moins minable mob cela vous apporter
un regard de minable sur cette algérie
alors oui / non ils sont comme ça et
tout moi moi j'entends bourlem sont de
sales samba là franchement je peux pas
entendre et après vous posez des
questions dix ans mais pourquoi on va
encore parler ou y at il un problème
entre la france et l'algérie les
algériens la colonisation la première
guerre mondiale la deuxième guerre
mondiale est-ce qu'ils ont été traitées
pareil est ce que on
2007 ribéry n'a plus parlé comme ça
c'est pas possible on peut pas insulter
les étapes comme ça ainsi que sa
composante et en plus malheureusement
peut-être pour vous c'est que nous
sommes partis pour vivre des millénaires
ensemble parce que nous sommes mêlés
nous avons tricoter notre histoire nous
en avions une très grosse partie ici non
pas parce qu'elle a quitté l'algérie
parce qu'elle mourrait de faim parce
qu'elle a eu une histoire qui démarre à
la colonisation ensemble mais c'est
terrible a
raconté cette blague
les gens viennent ici parce qu'ils
crèvent la faim là bas et qu'ici à tout
est gratos et on peut les écouter on a
le droit d'avoir des points de vue
différents nyerere murray insultes et
oui langil ou clémence qu'on n'est pas
d'accord avec vous on insulte que ce
succès c'est une curieuse façon de faire
le déaut musée c'est très franco
algérien comme c'est toujours la faute à
la france dès qu'on n'est pas d'accord
avec le laïus victimaire habituel des
visages d'algériens ont les insultes
madame je les insulte non mais je
croyais de surcroît que vous étiez
française donc je suis même pas de
concert mais je veux je sois là deux
mais je m'exprime pas ici en tant
qu'algérienne jeu mais que ça il faut
que je sente santander madame on sent
d'ailleurs avec son histoire on a
l'impression d'un compte ou des côtes
françaises avec son histoire et le rouge
et rosé entendu yamina vous engagez des
produits des oiseux avait des points de
vue différents - pierre vermeren pour
revenir sur le drame en un mot bref à ce
qu'on va passer à d'autres notre sujet
un mot je reviens ce qu'il nous est sûre
le hir à ça quand même donner à voir
alors j'entends bien qu' il ya des
problèmes très importants etc mais ça on
a quand même vu
parce qu'au fond on les connaît pas les
algériens
d'abord quand on va en algérie on les
connaît mais si on ne connaît pas on ne
connaît pas pour plein de raisons et là
on a vu quand même bon on n'a jamais vu
tout un peuple dans la rue mais enfin on
a quand même vu un minima des millions
ou quelques centaines de milliers de
personnes dans les rues d'algérie qui
était quand même enfin il ya eu d'abord
un extraordinaire humour par exemple il
ya eu beaucoup d'humour il ya eu
beaucoup de joie et beaucoup de
rencontres il ya eu beaucoup de
créativité alors voilà il faut pas faire
abstraction de tout mais c'est moi j'ai
trouvé ça très rassurant très
intéressant après les lourdeurs encore
une fois le co vide est arrivé à un
moment où là vous l'avez dit voilà très
bien mais voilà il ya quand même une
joie qui est apparue et qu'il faut pas
oublier
[Musique]
alors si vous le voulez bien on va
passer à des questions géostratégiques
la question des migrations et là la
question du terrorisme est aussi posée
islamistes comment vous voyez pierre
vermeren la coopération entre la france
et l'algérie pour lutter contre le
terrorisme au sahel
vous savez
les alors là il ya des états des
domaines où l'état algérien l état
français travaillent très bien ensemble
c'est notamment dans ce domaine bon bien
sûr il ya le niveau à part en détention
et puis il n'y aurait elle des
coopérations dans beaucoup de domaines
la coopération existait en particulier
dans ce domaine d'ô
que ya un contentieux historique entre
l'armée algérienne et certains services
de l'armée française s'est pas tout à
fait nouveau mais il ya beaucoup de des
changes
il ya beaucoup de coopération alors sur
l'afrique bien sûr c'est pas évident
parce que le lauréat a pour principe
inventé par l'algérie en 1963 un respect
absolu des frontières héritées de la
colonisation et la non-ingérence dans
les affaires des états c'est pourquoi la
france pendant des décennies n'a pas osé
une jusqu'à maintenant ne dit jamais
rien en gros sur ce qui se passe en
algérie parce qu'au fond la colonisation
c'est une ingérence et la décolonisation
c'est la fin de l'ingérence bon mais il
ya d'autres pays et le sahel finalement
à pousser alors il ya eu la libye
d'abord là c'est vrai que les algériens
ont beaucoup voulu à la france pour
avoir été mettre leur nez dans les
affaires libyennes mais au sahel
finalement ils ont senti le danger parce
que qui a semé le chaos qu à l eau au
sahel au départ alors parce qu'il ya des
influences du moyen-orient etc ce sont
aussi des islamistes ou des terroristes
algériens qui ont été chassés du
territoire qui sont allés s'installer là
bas et qui ont créé à la fin de la
guerre civile en algérie une sorte de
maquis où deux guérillas locale qui a
fini par manquer de prendre le pouvoir à
bamako et quand françois hollande a
décidé d'envoyer l'armée pour arrêter la
chute finalement du pouvoir à bamako les
algériens pour la première fois ont
laissé survoler leur territoire par des
avions de l'armée française on a vu que
cette coopération a pris fin récemment
puisque à nouveau les avions français ne
peuvent plus et même voir le pouvoir
algérien a facilité le disons le passage
de mercenaires russes qui ont eux mêmes
à leur tour ont mis les français dehors
bon donc c'est je ne dis pas que c'est
simple mais il ya une coopération existe
depuis les années 90 et les attentats de
paris elle a été très très forte et
parfois là où on ne l'attend pas c'est à
dire entre
pasqua par exemple charles pasqua à
partir de 1995 et le régime algérien il
ya eu beaucoup de beaucoup de travail en
commun et j'imagine que ça se poursuit
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est pas les points
les plus chauds aujourd'hui quand on
voit ce qui se passe alors écoutez il
nous reste très peu de temps je vais
vous faire réagir
tous les quatre et ce sera notre
dernière question vous êtes là boualem
sansal
alors on va conclure sur six volets bien
sur cette question selon un dernier
sondage harris interactive pour historia
réalisé respectivement dans les deux
pays la france et l'algérie ont des
appréciations mémorielle et politiques
distinctes nous l'avons vu sur ce
plateau sur l'à beaucoup de sujets que
nous avons évoqués il se trouve que dans
ce sondage fait en france et en algérie
un tiers des algériens comme un tiers
des français souhaitent que cessent les
relations entre les deux pays qu'est ce
que vous en pensez boualem sansal vous
avez chacun chacune une minute pour
répondre à cette question
qu'est ce qu'on peut penser de ça c'est
les 5 rue maufoux pas imaginer que
derrière de la population dans les deux
pays
je sais pas je mets en doute un peu ce
genre de son âge de non ça c'est honteux
écoutez c'est pas possible comme tout à
l'heure le disait yamina benguigui nous
sembla pour les milanais de nuire encore
donc vous trouvez il faut sortir des
problèmes que nous avons créé c'est pas
c'est pas des problèmes hérités de
l'histoire on les a créés avec le maire
il faut se dépasser ses problèmes et
puis il a conçu un navire c'est un jeu
mais ce travail qui le fait pour le
moment personne des deux côtés delà de
la frontière on regarde le passé
quand on voit ce élections aujourd'hui
aux tresses justifiez vous êtes en train
de justifier le titre de l'émission un
passé qui passe pas
oui mais voilà il faut se résoudre
mais s'ils veulent faire écouter c'est
dans
l'émission ce succès ce terme sont à
mon nom c'était un projet
où on a parlé des politiques dont on
oublie la société
les sociétés civiles
ont beaucoup à faire dans ce domaine les
états on peut considérer qu'ils sont au
prix dont vous parlez contingences les
contraintes c'est très difficile pour
eux ça on peut on peut comprendre mais
moi ce qui me désole c'est que les
sociétés civiles et intellectuels
algériens et actuel france voilà mais ce
n'est ce pas ensemble pour dénoncer les
uns et les autres et puis de me bâtir
quelque chose au regretté de nouveau
regretté de ne pas avoir comme
interlocuteur albert camus
ben voilà il nous faudrait des gens
comme ça
je pense que ce sont les intellectuels
qui font qu'ils font avancer les choses
merci gym sur ce sondage irles un bon un
mot pour dire que bouteflika avait
raison sur la libye et qu'on aurait bien
fait côté français de l'écouter à
l'époque quand il avait dit ne pas nous
en mêler ça veut dire qu' il peut y
avoir une coopération d'état et avec
l'algérie c'est ce que je me force est
de dire au début qu'ils soient libérés
de cette gangue de de mémoire qui est
utilisé de façon très politique par les
uns ou par les autres surtout par les
uns sur les 30% je suis pas surpris
malheureusement là encore une fois le
tout ce qui tourne du pouvoir algérien
dans la population algérienne s'est
quand même c'est toujours la faute de la
france et donc il ya une partie on peut
comprendre de cette population
algérienne qui a vécu la guerre ou key
qui a subi les conséquences de la guerre
qui en plus à qui on explique que c'est
tout le temps la faute de la france peut
comprendre que ces gens n'ont pas envie
d'avoir des relations avec la france
on attend d'elle même en france mêle
jeudi à yamina benguigui parce que moi
je le sais parce que je le vis et
longtemps longtemps à l'assemblée j'ai
fait cinq mandats ici je sais ce que
pour les concitoyens
l'immigration la menace islamiste le les
passe droits
des immigrés des algériens pas port au
vécu de français pauvres pauvres qui
n'en peuvent plus c'est une réalité et
mina et je suis pas du tout surpris que
30% des gens disent basta c'est la
vérité après comment on en sort on en
sort par une politique intelligente qui
consiste à arrêter cette espèce
d'autoflagellation permanente et j'en
veux au régime actuel d'avoir joué avec
ça en permanence c'est pas la pente vous
a entendu on guérir et l'immigration
géant vous à entendre lieu yamina sur le
sur le sondage et cette volonté des uns
et des autres d'europe qu'est ce que
vous en pensez mais moi je reviens à ma
casquette de réalisatrice je pense que
effectivement ce sont à la fois les
intellectuels et les cinéastes les
auteurs il faut
commencer et on commence seulement à
écrire nos histoires aussi bien les
rôtissoires française et grande histoire
algérienne et les peuples
moi je pense que les peuples sont
formidables je pense qu'on fait une
petite erreur aujourd'hui sur ce plateau
c'est qu'on imagine que nous parlons
d'algériens qui ont tous 80 ans qui y
sont parle de la guerre d'algérie nous
vous savez dans la dans l'inconscient
que l'on a parlé du passé du présent le
passé là c'est vrai si la guerre car les
années 80 les années 80 90 on était dix
ans des années charnières parce que
justement pierre on parle de l'islamisme
mais même à l'avènement de l'ayatollah
khomeini en 79 on s'est demandé comment
les musulmans étaient rentrés en france
ça nous a tous choqués on n'a pas le
temps de rentrer dans le débat
simplement y lit on doit pouvoir
aujourd'hui parler sereinement des
choses on ne voit bien que cette france
et cette algérie de toute façon on est
là pour vivre ensemble ils avaient dit
si vous voulez ce dont le peuple le
temps est presque clos un dernier mot
pierre vermeren sur le sondage si vous
voulez d'abord il ya les deux tiers qui
veulent continuer voilà donc ces on
n'est pas obligé de se focaliser sur un
tiers maintenant il faut jamais
désespérer vous savez la guerre entre la
france et le vietnam elle a été plus
meurtrières que la guerre d'algérie
les vietnamiens ont gagné la guerre
il ya plus d'animosité il ya beaucoup de
vietnamiens aussi qui habite en france
on n'en parle pas mais il y en a presque
un million et plus encore avec les
laotiens les cambodgiens dont il doit y
avoir des moyens de s'entendre et de
trouver des ponts même avec des sociétés
avec lesquelles on a eu des conflits et
des histoires très particulière merci
pierre vermeren de cette note
d'espérance alors il me reste à vous
présenter une bibliographie je rappelle
le livre de boris cyrulnik et boualem
sansal france algérie paru c'est odile
jacob
vous avez une oeuvre immense boualem
sansal on appris votre dernier ouvrage
vous l'être d'amitié de respect de mise
en garde aux peuples et aux nations de
la terre pierre vermeren le choc des
décolonisations
voilà je voudrais rappeler le dernier
livre de pierre lellouche une guerre
sans fin au cercle pierre lellouche
c'est quoi cette guerre sans fin combien
nous vivons aujourd'hui entre l'islam et
l'europe depuis qu'un siècle une grande
histoire pas toujours simple merci
madame merci boualem sansal
merci messieurs d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci à l'équipe de lcp
et avant de vous quitter je vous somme
et cette pensée de germaine tillon
j'aime la france qui m'a façonné et
j'aime l'algérie qui m'a passionné
elle a tout dit
[Musique]